Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Si TEDx avait existé il y a 140 ans,
je crois qu’on aurait eu plaisir
à recevoir ici-même Gustave Eiffel
pour lui poser la fameuse question :
« Mais enfin, monsieur Eiffel,
pourquoi voulez-vous à tout prix
construire cette tour métallique
de 300 mètres de haut entièrement vide ? »
Et il nous aurait répondu
avec cette petite étincelle dans l’œil
qui le caractérisait :
« Mais parce que c’est fantastique
de voir Paris d’en haut. »
Bonjour, je m’appelle Laurent,
je suis ingénieur et urbaniste.
Les ingénieurs, ce sont ces gens
qui postent des lettres à demain,
un petit peu, tous les jours.
Ils font des projets, ils les écrivent et
ils essayent surtout de suivre la lettre
pour que ça se réalise à peu près bien.
Et je suis urbaniste parce que je suis
passionné depuis très longtemps
par la façon dont on construit
les villes et dont on les habite.
Je suis venu aujourd’hui pour vous parler
de la façon dont nous allons reconquérir
les espaces aériens des villes
pour mieux y vivre,
comme le souhaitait Gustave Eiffel,
et peut-être bien davantage.
Aujourd’hui, sur la Terre,
des villes de plus d’un million
d’habitants, il y en a 500.
Il y en avait seulement 70 il y a 50 ans.
Donc, c’est un fait : le monde s’urbanise.
Les humains n’ont jamais en fin de compte
construit quelque chose d’aussi gros,
aussi vite
et avec autant de ressources
que les villes.
Un petit exemple.
Chaque Français consomme en moyenne
tous les ans six tonnes de matériaux
pour construire sa maison,
son bureau, ses routes,
son métro, ses infrastructures,
bref, sa ville.
C'est à peu près la moitié de tout
ce qu'il consomme dans l'année.
Six millions de tonnes de matériaux,
ça fait à peu près 16 kilos par jour.
J’aurais bien aimé demander à chacune,
à chacun, de venir aujourd’hui
avec deux petits seaux de 8 kilos chacun
de béton, de métal, de ce que vous voulez.
On les aurait posés ici sur l’estrade
et ça vous aurait donné une illustration
de ce que nécessite la construction
de nos villes aujourd’hui.
Et moi, ça m’aurait donné l’occasion de
vous parler depuis le haut d’une montagne.
Moi, ce qui me tracasse dans tout ça,
c’est que la ville, finalement,
on la construit comme au Moyen Âge.
Tous ces matériaux,
on essaye de les acheminer
jusqu’au lieu où on fait les chantiers,
à travers les espaces publics
dans lesquels on a déjà
mis toutes les mobilités,
dans lesquels on a déjà mis
tous les réseaux,
tous les accès aux commerces, aux bureaux.
Et aujourd’hui, pas de chance,
on veut encore y mettre
deux choses supplémentaires.
Premièrement, la nature en ville -
tout le monde s’accorde pour dire
que nos villes doivent être plus vertes -
et deuxièmement,
les systèmes de résilience
qui vont nous permettre
d’absorber le réchauffement climatique
avec en premier lieu,
les inondations et les îlots de chaleur.
J’ai réuni dans ma société 200 ingénieurs
et on a essayé de travailler à une
solution que je vous présente aujourd’hui,
qui est de prendre plus de légèreté,
d’essayer de regarder comment on peut,
en recolonisant les hauteurs de ville,
favoriser les choses, favoriser la vie.
Et ô surprise, on a découvert quelque
chose auquel on ne s’attendait pas.
C’est que les villes aériennes
ont toujours existé.
Non seulement elles ont toujours existé,
mais à chaque fois
qu’on a voulu les réaliser,
les êtres humains se sont surpassés.
Vous voulez voir ?
Prenons le pont du Gard.
Deux mille ans que cet ouvrage
exceptionnel nous montre
comment prendre de la hauteur
avec un minimum de matière.
Plus près de nous, les lignes aériennes
du métro parisien, les lignes 2 et 6.
Avouez que ce sont celles
qu’on a le plus de plaisir à prendre.
Cette belle infrastructure,
ce voyage au troisième étage de la ville
que l’on expérimente tous les jours,
bien plus agréable en tout cas,
que le métro souterrain.
Mais saviez-vous qu’à la même époque
que Gustave Eiffel,
tout le monde était d’accord
pour dire que c’était la totalité du métro
qui devait être construite
sur les toits de Paris ?
Parce qu’on considérait à l’époque
que voyager en souterrain
allait être trop anxiogène ?
Plus près de nous, la High Line
à New York,
cette fameuse coulée verte qui permet
de se promener sur les hauteurs de ville,
est devenue le symbole de New York,
le symbole de sa réconciliation
avec la nature,
et celui d’un renouveau touristique, avec
plusieurs millions de visiteurs par an.
Mais vous ne savez peut-être pas que la
High line est inspirée du Viaduc des Arts
que vous avez à deux pas d’ici,
qui a été construit trente ans plus tôt
et qui relie l’arrière de la Bastille
au [bois] de Vincennes.
Plus ambitieux,
le Marina Bay Sands à Singapour,
et cette incroyable plateforme
perchée à 200 mètres de haut,
qui abrite une forêt et soi-disant
la plus [haute] piscine du monde.
Et pour finir, je ne résiste pas
à évoquer Hundertwasser,
ce génial artiste architecte
viennois qui considérait
que les hommes ne devaient pas
être locataires des immeubles,
mais les arbres,
et qui a fait d’ailleurs des réalisations
partout dans le monde
où les immeubles soutiennent des forêts
et des massifs forestiers.
Ce que je suis venu vous témoigner,
c’est que maintenant,
on va pouvoir capitaliser
tous ces héritages,
toutes ces petites expérimentations,
pour aller beaucoup plus loin.
Et c’est donc le programme que
je vous propose de regarder maintenant.
Premièrement, coloniser
tous les toits qui le peuvent.
Il y a des milliers de toits
qui sont accessibles.
Récemment, on a déjà colonisé quelques
petits rooftops pour faire la fête.
Eh bien, continuons.
Faisons en sorte d’activer tous ces toits
et faisons surtout en sorte qu’ils soient
gratuits et accessibles à tous.
Pas de ségrégation
dans la ville verticale.
Une fois que vous aurez conquis quelques
petits points comme ça dans la ville,
on va essayer de les relier.
C’est assez facile en fin de compte
de relier deux immeubles
avec des infrastructures relativement
légères pour commencer,
en bois, en métal, en béton,
en ce que vous voulez.
Si vous n’arrivez pas à les relier,
vous allez pouvoir capitaliser
sur des infrastructures
qui vont supporter en fin de compte
vos espaces aériens.
Là, on a un petit peu de chance
parce qu’en ingénierie, des fois,
on travaille par biomimétisme,
c’est-à-dire qu’on s’inspire de la nature
pour construire des infrastructures.
Et qui mieux que la nature
sait monter vers le haut,
n’est-ce pas, les amis ?
Profitons de la nature
et essayons de regarder
comment imaginer des infrastructures
qui poussent par exemple,
ou qui s’hybrident avec des arbres,
ou bien qui s’accrochent aux façades
des immeubles comme le ferait du lierre ?
Comme ça, peu à peu,
vous allez commencer à composer
un réseau un peu hybride
qui va venir coloniser
les hauteurs de ville
et vous allez pouvoir de temps
en temps ponctuer ce réseau
par des infrastructures
un peu plus robustes
qui vont permettre de faire les travaux.
J’en reviens à ce que je disais :
les travaux, il faut les faire
depuis les toits des immeubles,
depuis des infrastructures aériennes,
pour une raison toute simple,
c’est qu’il est très facile d’acheminer
et d’enlever des grandes charges
avec des ballons dirigeables.
Donc évitons d’engorger les espaces
publics avec des milliers de camions
et inventons les plateformes de travaux
situées dans les espaces
aériens des villes.
Ensuite, vous allez compléter
un petit peu votre schéma
en favorisant des liaisons verticales.
C’est-à-dire que vous allez
choisir des immeubles,
vous allez les rénover
et vous allez les spécifier
pour tirer le maximum
de parti de leur verticalité :
vous allez y accrocher
des éléments naturels,
y faire couler de l’eau,
y cultiver des choses.
Vous allez pouvoir y faire de la culture
et vous allez aussi pouvoir y intégrer
tous les systèmes de mobilité,
verticaux et horizontaux,
qui vont vous permettre de monter
et de conquérir les espaces aériens.
Et puis, cerise sur le gâteau,
vous allez pouvoir profiter de l’ensemble
pour fabriquer de l’énergie.
Parce qu’en fin de compte, la façon
la plus simple de produire de l’énergie,
c’est de profiter de la pesanteur.
Donc perchons de l’eau.
On peut faire turbiner de l’eau
en la faisant descendre,
on peut la faire remonter
quand on a de l’énergie solaire.
L’idée, c’est également de réinventer des
cycles énergétiques vertueux, autonomes
au sein même des villes.
Voilà l’ensemble de l’écosystème
que pourrait constituer la fabrication de
cette nouvelle façon de vivre les villes,
comme l’avaient esquissé Gustave Eiffel
et bien d’autres.
Et petit à petit, vous allez pouvoir
ponctuer tous ces espaces aériens
de nouveaux services : services de santé,
services sociaux,
services de loisirs,
et de la même façon, vous allez
libérer petit à petit l’espace naturel
pour y replanter cette fameuse forêt,
cette fameuse nature
que l’on attend tous aujourd’hui.
Pour finir, je voudrais aussi vous dire
que cela permettra
de mieux absorber les dérèglements
climatiques qui nous accompagnent,
avec en premier lieu, la montée
des eaux pour les villes littorales
et les inondations pour les autres.
Voilà, très vite, la lettre à demain
que je voulais partager avec vous.
Vous voyez, je suis convaincu
qu’il existe une autre façon de dessiner,
d’imaginer et même de réaliser
les villes puisque c’est déjà fait.
Je vous invite peut-être à en reparler
dans quelques années
pour voir si tout ça
est réellement fait pour de bon.
Je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté dans
cet amphithéâtre vraiment prestigieux,
mais tout de même, accordez-le-moi,
un peu sombre.
Je vous promets que la prochaine fois, on
se retrouvera sur le toit de la Sorbonne.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)